- [Instructor] Ammonia is
an example of a weak base.
and hydrochloric acid is an
example of a strong acid.
Ammonia reacts with hydrochloric acid
to form an aqueous solution
of ammonium chloride.
And because this is an acid-base
neutralization reaction,
there's only a single
arrow going to the right,
indicating the reaction
goes to completion.
Next, let's write the overall
or complete ionic equation.
Let's start with ammonia.
Ammonia is a weak base,
and weak bases only partly
ionize in aqueous solution.
Therefore, since weak
bases only partly ionize,
we're not gonna show this as an ion.
We're simply gonna write
NH3 in our equation.
However, for hydrochloric acid,
hydrochloric acid is a strong acid,
and strong acids ionize 100%.
Therefore, an aqueous solution,
we need to show this as the ions,
so H plus and Cl minus.
Ammonium chloride is a soluble salt,
therefore, an aqueous solution,
we show it as the ions.
So ammonium chloride
consists of the ammonium ion,
NH4 plus, and the
chloride anion, Cl minus.
To save some time,
I've drawn in the aqueous subscripts,
and also put in the reaction
arrow and a plus sign.
So this represents the overall,
or the complete ionic equation.
And we can use the complete ionic equation
to find the net ionic equation
for this weak base, strong acid reaction.
To do that, we first need to
identify these spectator ions.
And remember, these are the
ions that do not take part
in the chemical reaction.
Since there's a chloride
anion on the left side
and on the right side,
the chloride anion is the
spectator ion for this reaction.
And once we take out our spectator ion,
we're left with our net ionic equation,
which is aqueous ammonia
plus H plus yields NH4 plus.
So this is one way to write
our net ionic equation.
However, remember that H plus and H3O plus
are used interchangeably in chemistry.
Therefore, another way to
write the net ionic equation
is to show aqueous ammonia
plus the hydronium ion,
H3O plus, yields the ammonium
ion, NH4 plus, plus water.
Now that we have our net ionic equation,
we're gonna consider three
different situations.
In the first situation,
we have equal moles of our
weak base and strong acid.
Looking at our net ionic equation,
the mole ratio of ammonia to
hydronium ion is one to one.
Therefore, if we have equal
moles of our weak base
and strong acid,
the weak base and strong acid
will completely neutralize each other
and produce the ammonium ion NH4 plus.
So if our goal is to figure out the pH
of the resulting solution,
we don't need to consider the weak base,
or this strong acid.
We need to think about the ammonium cation
in aqueous solution.
And in solution,
the ammonium cation acts as a weak acid
and donates a proton to water
to form the hydronium ion,
H3O plus, and aqueous ammonia.
The ammonium cation, NH4
plus, is a weak acid.
Therefore, the Ka value is less than one.
And since Ka is less
than one at equilibrium,
there are mostly reactants
and not very many products.
However, the concentration
of hydronium ions in solution
is increased, and therefore,
the resulting solution will be acidic.
So the resulting solution
will be slightly acidic.
And at 25 degrees Celsius,
the pH of the solution
will be less than seven.
If we wanted to calculate the actual pH,
we would treat this like a
weak acid equilibrium problem.
Also, it's important to
emphasize that the hydronium ions
that gave the resulting
solution a pH less than seven
came from the reaction of the
ammonium cation with water.
The hydronium ions did not
come from the strong acid.
All of those hydronium ions were used up
in the acid-base neutralization reaction.
For the second situation,
we have more of the weak
base than the strong acid,
therefore, we have the
weak base in excess.
And because the mole
ratio of the weak base
to the strong acid is one to one,
if we have more of the weak
base than the strong acid,
all of the strong acid will be used up.
So when the reaction goes to completion,
we'll have ammonium cations in solution,
and we'll also have some leftover ammonia.
So after the neutralization
reaction is complete
and all the H3O plus is used up,
we'll have some leftover ammonia.
That ammonia will react with water
to form hydroxide anions and NH4 plus.
Because the concentration of
hydroxide ions in solution
has increased at 25 degrees Celsius,
the resulting solution will be basic
and the pH will be greater than seven.
If we wanted to calculate the actual pH,
we would treat this like a
weak base equilibria problem.
However, we have two sources
for the ammonium cation.
One source is from ammonia
reacting with water
to form NH4 plus,
and the other source came from
the neutralization reaction.
So actually, this would be
a common-ion effect problem.
The other way to calculate
the pH of this solution
is to realize that ammonium
NH4 plus is a weak acid,
and ammonia NH3 is its conjugate base,
therefore, if we have similar
amounts of a weak acid
and its conjugate base,
we have a buffer solution
and we could calculate
the pH using the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
For our third situation,
let's say we have the
strong acid in excess.
Since the mole ratio of
weak base to strong acid
is one to one,
if we have more of the strong
acid than the weak base,
all of the weak base will be used up
and we'll have some strong acid in excess.
Therefore, there'll be a
concentration of hydronium ions
in solution, which would make
the resulting solution acidic.
So at 25 degrees Celsius, the
pH would be less than seven.
We could calculate the actual
pH of the resulting solution
by doing a strong acid
pH calculation problem.
And while it's true
that the ammonium cation
can function as a weak acid
and also increase the
concentration of hydronium ions,
it's such a small increase compared to
the hydronium ions we have in
solution from our strong acid
that we don't need to worry
about the contribution
of the ammonium cations.
We can just treat this
like a strong acid pH calculation problem.